ha sido una jornada bastante digamos
extraña la población amaneció con la
expectativa de que cómo iba a responder
Vladimir Putin a este primer año de
guerra en el que no obviamente no pudo
cumplir esas expectativas que tenía
exactamente hace un año según lo ha
dicho el alcalde de la ciudad al menos
el 70% de la población había intentado
buscar otro refugios o a otros Lugares
cercanos a kiev o al oeste del país
nosotros vimos gente pero vimos muy muy
poca gente Comparado con un día laboral
un viernes cualquiera especialmente en
los últimos meses cuando la gente había
vuelto Aquí también Vimos una cantidad
de eventos para recordar lo que ha sido
este año y especialmente no solamente a
quienes han fallecido o a los heridos
durante esta guerra sino también para
manejar quienes han defendido este país
Así que hemos visto al presidente zelens
que en el centro en la plaza de Santo
Sofía Dando
conmemorando y dando medallas de honor
algunos de los combatientes estuvimos
esta mañana también en la iglesia de San
Miguel de esas cúpulas doradas donde
también estaban haciendo homenaje y así
alrededor de la ciudad la gente
recordando con velas con flores yendo a
los lugares donde se recuerdan aquellas
personas que han fallecido defendiendo
al país que recordemos que no solamente
son militares o voluntarios que se
unieron a las defensas territoriales son
civiles son niños pero también gente que
trabajó como paramédico la gente que
trabajó en emergencias en rescatistas
Así que ha sido un día muy sentimental
muy sentido en la ciudad de kiev donde
no han sonado las alarmas ha sido una
gran sorpresa la gente dice que esta es
una de esas tantas Sorpresas del
Vladimir Putin que es impredecible y se
están preguntando que estará planeando
para los próximos días